the ocean has been my passion since i
was young
i used to dream of being jack cousteau
exploring the seven seas with my team
but in just a few generations
the underwater world has changed
dramatically all over the planet so many
places are now void of life
our destruction of the natural world
isn't just happening underwater
what can take millennia to create can be
destroyed in hours
consequences for us are dire
far-reaching and often
unexpected
[Music]
i've spent my entire life studying
natural ecosystems in places both
pristine and degraded
and have worked for 30 years to help
save what's left
[Music]
we have doubled the total area protected
in the ocean
our life support system depends on all
other species and intact natural spaces
without them
everything falls out of balance
but nature is a sustainable resilient
and regenerative engine it's time we get
out of the way and let it work for us
today the world is at the crossroads
but if we understand the nature of
nature
if we change our current trajectory
there is hope
[Music]
you